[Music]
we have here today the um I would say
you did both you did both you fulfilled
the Brown man's obligation you became a
doctor but then you fulfilled the dream
in your heart and you became a content
creator and you are now one of the most
popular YouTubers productivity guys that
people know on YouTube this is Ali abdal
welcome to the Pod man I've been
watching you for a while it's uh it's
fun to have you here thanks so much and
I've been a fan of the Pod for years now
it hard to believe it's been years
because I remember when you guys first
started out and it was actually you know
how did you make your first million I
was like who what a great concept for a
podcast starting a podcast and everyone
needed an angle and the my first million
angle was just so good and I've been
keeping up with you guys on Twitter and
stuff for for ages as well so it's super
nice to be here you gave us a big shout
out early on in our podcast I think you
did a video where it was like 10
podcasts that I like right now or
something like that and that was a big
deal for us that was when you that was
when my first million was still a small
podcast and I was like I've discovered
something there's these two guys who
like ask people how they made their
first million this is incredible stuff I
remember when I dm' Sam the name of the
podcast I was like I think I'm I think
about calling it this and he was just
like it's so bad and I was like I'm like
coming up with my response he goes that
it's
perfect Sam why did you why did you
think it was so bad what is that so bad
that it's perfect well I'm not
particularly good at naming things my
company was called The Hustle so I'm not
good at naming things Sean you're
actually quite good at naming things but
it was for some reason it was it just I
think that we've done a good job of
appearing to be like internet markety
Shady almost like on the surface like
when I go to the barber and they say
what do I do for a living and I I want
to cringe when I say the name of the Pod
but then I'm like but it's not what it
sounds like and so we I think it's a
good name because it grabs your
attention but we've done a good job of
staying on the right side of I think
like doing the right stuff and having
good taste that's honest I think I think
it's a fantastic name I I came across
some occasionally people on Twitter like
to hate on Clips in the podcast I think
because you guys are so open about
talking about money and there was a
quote tweet that I saw being like lol I
can't you know what would you expect
from a podcast called my first million
and I was like that's perfect that's
exactly what you'd expect from a podcast
called my first million and I think the
name is amazing and yeah I just love I
just love how Brazen you guys are about
talking about money loved the Neil Patel
episode in particular you were just like
asking him so specific questions huge
huge huge fan of the show he to this day
I give him credit he's the only guy that
has a absurdly high life burn rate his
burn rate for month was I think
180,000 he just said it matter of factly
he's like that's what I spend for a
month me and Sam fell out of our chair
and we're like What are you spending
180,000 on and then he's like what do
you mean of course I need that here I
need that and he's like explained it
390s my two housekeepers my all of that
stuff that Tik Tok clip has like 10
million views because it's the whole
comment section just hates him in that
for saying that but I respect him for
coming on here and standing he he told
his truth what did the kid say that's
your truth man you stood by your truth
so interestingly just on on the Neil
Patel note uh I was at a a mastermind
that he was speaking at and I asked him
a question because our business was
doing I don't know 5 million revenue or
something like that and he was like man
why are you in the info products
business all you can make with info
product is like 5 milon you should be in
the agency business CU you can make a
100 million in the agency business and I
was like oh but like I want a lifestyle
business I want to chill out agency seem
very stressful and he was like man I
probably work less than you do I work
like four five six hours a week and I've
got hundred million do agency and then
his CEO from the back of the room piped
up and he was like no no no hang on hang
on Neil's bullshitting right now every
we have 800 employees we have so many
people problems he's stressed all the
time like do not think that running an
agency is an easy business to be
in just for the record I love that
and I love that his CEO called him him
out because you do you know our good
friend Andrew Wilkinson and I think Sean
and I are also victim to this as well
where we oversimplify things and we act
like it's it's no big deal it's very low
stress and that's not the reality I was
just texting my friend Austin Reef who
runs morning brew and like morning Brew
is a similar thing where on paper
they're killing it on behind the scenes
or uh in the public eye they're killing
it and they are killing it and it's so
simple it's just a newsletter wow news
yeah how H can it be yeah and you know
what we were bitching to each other
about we were both saying how we have
the Sunday scaries I was like I've got
to do this podcast I got to prepare I've
got this meeting and that meeting and
then I got to go do run this errand and
I think that it is not it it looks cool
just like your life Ali your your life
particularly looks cool you share your
Revenue you're making profit you're
living a nomadic life you got a book
coming out you seem well you know you're
put together there all of our [__]
stinks and it's all significantly more
stressful than I think and it looks like
what what's the uh what's the hot mess
part of your life Ali the hot mess part
of my life is that I generally don't
enjoy filming YouTube videos uh which is
do right yeah
exactly there are there are lots of
aspects about being a YouTuber that I
really like and sometimes I enjoy making
videos but I've made like 750 videos to
date where I just speak to the camera
and I've maybe enjoyed filming like 20
of them and it's kind of weird because
like I I love the reading the
synthesizing the learning but when it
comes to sitting down like you know I I
love doing podcasts because there's
someone else on the other end and it's
like there's energy it's more fun but
just speaking to a camera on my own like
it's kind of depressing um but hey you
know that's that's the price to get the
message out there and and I do enjoy
other aspects of the process what else
do you hate about it you said that there
you said there's a few things you like
and there's a bunch of stuff you dislike
what do you what else do you dislike I
don't like doing sponsorship ad reads I
this is going to sound like very like
first world problems cuz you know a
sponsor ad read is I have to sort of
stumble through my words doing it every
which way the brand says that oh you
have to say the wording in this specific
way and then I'm kind of like yeah it
takes me 20 minutes to do like a
60-second adre just because of all the
stumbling and stuff that's that's that's
going through there by the way our
producer be honest our producer Ari is
like grimacing because Sean's actually
pretty good with words I Stumble a lot
but I you so hubspot's our main sponsor
I use HubSpot I like the product I own
the stock whatever and I still freaking
hate what they tell me to say because
they phrase it such a way where I'm like
that's not how I would say I didn't even
know this feature existed so like it
sucks man I'll do it'll take me an hour
to do about five minutes worth of reads
hey guys it's Q4 winning time and is
with the new sales prospecting tool it's
like oh God do I have to are you sure I
have to say this or listen to this I
can't even our podcast on the script
they write read this word for word
please do not change this one because
like we have one we have some we get to
improvise and some we don't or we'll do
our reads and it's like check out my
first million wherever you get your
podcast you know
like I don't even like doing our
reads yeah uh we actually switched to
HubSpot like two weeks ago um for or
rather have started using HubSpot for
our CRM because we never really had a
CRM for our course sales and revops and
all that stuff is that because it's Q4
and it's winning time it's Q4 and it's
winning time
actually may actually like I did my
first HubSpot adre yesterday because
they're now sponsoring my videos as well
which is cool it's like as soon as we
switched to them they gave us a discount
on the package they're sponsoring the
videos they're really good H love
HubSpot check out HubSpot
everyone our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better um I wanted
to ask ask you about some of your
productivity stuff because if I go to
your YouTube channel which I have many
times and I'll be honest when I usually
go there I'm like
okay he seems like so like such a good
guy like someone you'd want to be
friends with but I was like in terms of
YouTube success he's not the the
funniest he's not the sexiest he's not
the smartest he's not the most
successful guy on the platform but you
really win and you do really well and
one of the things you do well is you
just share very useful just useful
things and I think useful was actually
kind of underrated um so instead of
trying to impress everybody you just try
to be a little bit helpful like a you
know like a friend helping you out and
you had this list of productivity things
you do you probably got like 50 YouTube
videos about productivity but you did
this Twitter list that I thought was
really good which was how you are more
productive than the average person and I
want to read you some of these and I
want you to explain what they are
because I didn't by the way Sean for the
record he ranks pretty high on like the
sexiest he's got the good London accent
he's a doctor
like he's dressed nice at least two
notches above average on all of those
things he's not the most in the world
right like uh like if I go on Twitch
there's some twitch streamers where I'm
like I understand why she's doing well
this this makes sense to me why this
would appeal to people on this platform
right I get it um all right so anyways
let's go back to your productivity stuff
so you have a technique you call the
daily highlight what is the daily
highlight uh one thing I would say
before is before talking about this
stuff this thread that you're
referencing thing was actually a bit of
a experiment I did a year ago where I
got chat GPT to write the whole thing
before chat GPT was cool uh so the first
two are legit and the rest are just pure
it's all [__] made up by Ai and a
few days I was blown away your best work
I thought and a few days after I posted
the thread I did another thread talking
about how that thread was AI generated
and now it's not news anymore because
everyone's doing this but like at the
time people were like oh my God AI is
taking over our jobs AI is taking over
the world but the day highlight is legit
the daily highlight is a technique
basically where you ask yourself what is
the most important thing I need to do
today and that's it like it's one of the
by far the most simple productivity tip
you could possibly have but it's so
needle moving because so few of us
actually Focus down on what is the most
important thing I personally like to
phrase it as what's today's adventure
going to be because my whole shtick is
to really to be productive you got to
find a way to enjoy the process and even
just reframing something in your mind as
an adventure makes you way more likely
to enjoy the process it's so true like
we are all children inside and we can
use all of these different tactics to
make us feel good about the things that
we're doing and Adventure framing is is
one of them so that's the daily
highlight with my kids whenever I need
them to do something or like walk
somewhere to do something like if I just
say hey let's go over here they'll never
like just wander around they won't come
I'm like come on come on let's go but if
I'm like hey guys it's a mission we have
to find your jackets before we go
outside and I'm like it's a mission like
it's a mission and then they get really
excited and then yesterday by myself I I
couldn't find my uh my laptop I was like
ready to do some work couldn't I had no
idea where I put it in my house and I
just told myself Sean it's Mission and I
got kind of excited not gonna lie the
third grade teacher technique Works Sam
do you do this kind of one highlight
like he says he calls it daily highlight
I call it the one big thing where my
to-do I have a to-do list of one do you
do something like that or do you have a
long to-do list every day look I know
what the audience is thinking they think
Sam you're this wonderfully attractive
man you're so charismatic you're so
productive but truth is is I actually
struggle with this I I just have a to-do
list I keep a notebook here and I just
like make my list in the morning and
frankly I find it very stressful and
like not my productivity scheme is I
find very unproductive what I believe
and I actually think this is uh I
believe Sean might do this too and I
think this is actually maybe wrong of us
is I leave a lot of open space and I
just kind of Follow My Heart of like
what's going on and I used to tell
myself well Paul Graham said it's the
manager versus the the artist yeah the
maker schedule and it's okay to have
open space and I find myself getting
really stress when I have things on my
calendar but I found myself just messing
around uh far too often than I should be
probably the the manager schedule the
maker schedule and then the skater boy
schedule around the house you know like
uh what did Warren Buffett said we made
a joke but it was real Warren Buffett
says he just reads all day so I would
just read like fiction books and I'm
like oh I'm productive it turns out he's
reading like annual reports you know
he's working at actually but no I find
my my I find my productivity schedule to
be pretty shitty and I'm actually I
wrote down the daily highlight and then
the next one you have is The Hourglass
uh I find some of those like little
tricks actually helpful but I don't do
anything do you Sean well I do the the
one big I call it the one big thing in
fact I had somebody build me a Chrome
extension so that every time I opened a
tab it would say your one big thing is
and it's just a huge like text of what's
the one thing and the beauty of this is
um what I used to do like I used to do a
to-do list list and here's how you
here's how I would do the to-do list uh
it would be written down so there's no
particular order like I wouldn't rank it
by like kind of most urgent or important
I would just sort of write down the
things as they came to mind and then I
would like it's like if it's a plate of
food I would just go for the french
fries first every time so I would always
do the thing that's not actually the
thing I do I do the easy one I would
talk myself into oh it's getting me a
momentum and then I would go on a
tangent and I would just never get the
important [__] done and I would never
finish the to-do list everything I did
would add stuff add more things to
to the to-do list oh I emailed this guy
okay I got to follow up he said send him
the deck now I got to make it make the
deck I gota right so I was always adding
and it just was a source of stress so I
had this um my coach my trainer he said
this thing to me he goes uh you know
what if you did it a little bit
differently so you know like what's one
thing where if you just had this one
outcome of the day the whole day is a
success whether you did anything else or
not is there such a thing and if there's
not then you're sort of like hunting
mice you're just nibbling on little
stuff you don't have anything that's
actually impactful that you're that
you're striving towards but if you have
one impactful thing then that one thing
should be enough for the day imagine
just doing the one most important thing
every day for 365 days out of the year
you would outpace all the productivity
nerds out there I've got these days Ali
where like I feels like I was busy all
day and at the end of the day I've got
nothing done do you know what I mean
mate I know exactly what you mean yeah I
feel bad at the end of the day I don't
feel good yeah I find that that happens
for me a lot when I have like the day
chocola block with calendar events and
that's when I find that like you know as
Sean said I I haven't made time to do
the one big thing the daily highlight
the adventure whatever the [__] you want
to call it and just honestly just doing
that thing makes such a huge difference
to everything else because it's like
you've hunted the big thing and now you
can hunt the mice if you really want to
because like the small stuff does build
up and it's important to you send that
email send the followup all that crap
but actually the thing that's really
going to get you to where you want to be
is generally making big progress on that
one big thing and by the way it's not
one big task I don't do it as one task
it's one like outcome you're going for
like oh today I'm going to find the
right person for this role which might
involve me doing five tasks like go
through the applications short list the
best five email them and research them
or whatever right like whatever it is
schedule a call with them but like it's
one outcome that you're going for um
what's this hourglass one is this is
this for like time boxing yeah so The
Hourglass one is is is interesting so
one of the things that I've discovered
about procrastination from doing a bunch
of reading and interviewing professors
about this [__] is that procrastination
is generally a problem with getting
started with doing the thing because
usually once you've gotten started like
you have momentum and then you can like
finish you know it becomes a lot easier
to sustain the thing once you've gotten
started and so how do we how do we hack
our brains into just starting a task and
back when I wasn't traveling around the
world digital nomading I would have a f
minute hourglass on my desk and I would
just be like all right going to film the
video for just five minutes and i' turn
The Hourglass over and I would just
genuinely tell myself I'm just doing it
for five minutes and then usually I'm
I'm into the flow of it and then The
Hourglass time is way gone and I've I'm
now into the flow with the task but
sometimes I would just do the thing for
five minutes and it's just a little
practical I I I like physical things
that help boost my productivity because
it's like yeah you could set a timer on
your phone but then you see notification
and blah the the phone is too much of a
multitasking tool whereas literally an
hourglass that's five minutes is has one
tool and that is this is the thing that
stops me from
procrastinating that's fascinating so
you're saying that's a fascinating
Insight procrastination is not um I'm
putting off finishing the thing it's I'm
push putting off starting the thing and
as soon as you start you're light you
know you're it's actually quite easy to
just keep going and finish the thing for
most people yeah absolutely the law of
inertia it's like if you're you know one
I I I still struggle with working out
but if I just get myself to the gym and
just do something for five minutes I'm
there already I might as well keep going
and it's kind of fun and I kind of get
the endorphin rush and all that but it's
that first step of like getting you know
going downstairs to the hotel gym or
wherever I am these days and actually
just lifting the first weight that's by
far the hardest part and that's the
hardest part of any task just getting
started I um I went to this like
conference on Thursday and Friday Sean
do you know Nick Gray of course I know
Nick Gray he's the uh the inventor of
the two-hour cocktail party there there
really wasn't one until he he made it
Ally do you know ni who have you seen
Nick Ray yeah we hung out in Austin a
few months ago great guy yeah so he's a
character he's like a type of guy where
you think you're hanging out with him
and you're like is this a stick are you
just acting and it's not like like for
example my wife and I got lunch with him
one day and he goes all right I have a
list of topics first I want to talk
about my dating life and then at 11:24
we're going to switch Sarah to what
you're doing at work and then at
11:44 uh Sam I want to ask you an update
on this thing like and it's like that's
like his real life and it's it's like
exhausting at first and then you realize
it's pretty wonderful to hang out super
intentional he's like the walking
equivalent of may I have a
kiss yeah he's like he's he's he's wild
and for his 41st birthday he wanted to
host a conference that's what he wanted
to do and so he convinced Cloud Flair
which is a stock that he owns and he
loves and so that's why he did it there
he convinced them to let him have this
40% event there and he had all these
people come um and it was 40 people or
so and we basically just went into
groups of eight and we would discuss a a
topic that was like it could have been
parenting and you could go to the
parenting one it could have been
whatever and there was a bunch of
YouTubers there so there was Patty
Galloway who's a really fascinating guy
and this other guy I met who I didn't
know at the time his name was Josh
wisman have you guys heard of Josh
wisman he's a chef the chef he's a chef
youber incredible YouTuber like n
million subscribers yeah yeah or more I
think it's like 11 million it's a lot
and he was in the investing one with me
so we were talking about finances and
then I um there was a bunch of other
YouTubers there and it was first of all
it was one of the best events I've ever
been to I've met so many interesting
people but second there was like
birthday conference you ever been to
best best 41st birthday conference I've
ever been to dude there was this one
time so Nick owns a bunch of cloud flare
stock and he goes hey I convinced a VP
of cloud fair to come down here to meet
me he has no idea what he's walking into
and and he goes when you guys get here I
need you to start cheering for him and
telling him how much you love Cloud
flare and so this guy this like he's the
VP of engine he just walks in and he
think he's just meeting Nick and we're
like is that the VP of engineerium cloud
flare tell us your mission and he goes
oh Cloud Fair's mission is to make sure
the internet doesn't go down and we're
like I believe and we're like screaming
and cheering and he like convinced this
guy and he never told the guy that this
was a joke so to this day this guy still
thinks that we were there to like
discuss how much we love Cloud Flair uh
it was amazing but anyway all these
YouTubers were there and about half of
them didn't first of all they're making
so much money I didn't it would be like
a 26 or 27 year old guy who's making
maybe 10 million a year if I had to
guess a lot of them don't it didn't and
by the way you want to know the craziest
thing a lot of them they the biggest
problem that they were discussing was
like they kept a lot of their cash just
in a checking account as opposed to like
investing it because they were afraid to
put it even into a high yield savings
account which blew my mind of how many
successful people do that but a lot of
them it seemed didn't run their business
like a business they ran it like almost
a hobby but the numbers were
astronomical making a million dollars a
month I imagine but it seems like you're
your business like a real business and
like you've hired like I don't know 15
or 20 people um have you seen this with
a lot of these YouTubers where they're
just like it's like run like a 26 year
old who's just creative as opposed to a
a
business yeah yeah I see this quite a
lot this is like the biggest thing I
talk about when I hang out with other
YouTubers uh I haven't met many who are
like 27 and doing tens of millions uh
without treating it like a business I
think that would that that's a very
unusual state to be and by the way I'm
not referring to that guy joshh I'm just
referring to in general I met people I
don't want to like break any
confidentiality thing um yeah in general
what I find is that a lot of a lot of
YouTubers um they're creatives at heart
and not business people at heart which
is why they started YouTube in the first
place and they have this Reliance on
AdSense and brand deals in particular
like I know I know a couple people with
like millions of subscribers who are so
stressed and kind of hate their lives
because every video has to get a million
views because if it doesn't get a
million views then their brand deals
revenue is going to go down and they
need that brand deal revenue and
especially entertainment YouTubers find
it really hard to monetize off of the
platform because it's not you can't just
sell a course if you're an entertainment
you all you can do is sell a course on
how to do YouTube which your audience
doesn't want anyway we saw Yes Theory
you know you guys know yes Theory uh you
know 10 million subscribers they tried
to release a course about doing YouTube
and the audience hated them for it and
we released our course on like the same
day about how to do YouTube We charged
five times as much and our audience
loved us for it so it's like there's
this weird thing where entertainment
YouTubers in particular are reliant on
brand deals and that's a very stressful
existence and I think business ifying
and operationalizing and stuff is like
the way a lot of these guys level up
there was this one guy there who had
this big audience and he said we were
talking about cancelation like getting
canceled for saying the wrong thing
particularly with Israel and Palestine
going on and like taking a stand and do
you have to that was like the the
discussion and this one guy was like
I've basically created an audience
that's going to cancel me sometime in
the near future I don't know when but I
know it's going to happen and uh and
like that it was a really stressful uh
uh a stressful life he seemed like he
had he's like they're going to like I'm
their monkey at the moment and I'm
dancing for them but they're gonna come
after me eventually and it seemed really
stressful to be living that
life yeah pretty stressful place to
me I know one of one of my big things is
all about like treating create treating
treating the Creator thing more like a
business because like almost no one that
I speak to actually treats it like a
business and I think if you do learn if
someone's listening to this and they're
a Creator if you learn like the basics
of business like what is an sop and
reading books like the emth and traction
and things like that you end up with
like oh [__] I can apply all of these
principles of business okrs and kpis and
[__] to my YouTube channel and therefore
I can like oh I can use a CRM I can use
HubSpot I can drive sales to a product
oh that's cool and you get this whole
new skill set which then serves you for
the rest of your life but also really
benefits your your YouTube channel or
whatever the thing might be well let's
put up on the screen on on YouTube your
you did this you you're very open about
how much money you make and uh you show
your Revenue year by year so
2017 you did
$227 which was your AdSense Revenue when
you got started but then it goes
24,000 uh 130,000 so I want to point out
here you're now three years in and you
were a doctor so you're in three years
basically making less of what a kind of
traditional full-on doctor would would
make I think you were like in your your
um whatever the UK version of residency
is some version of that but then 20 in
2020 you jump from 130,000 up to 1.2
million uh what happened there in that
jump was that you released the course
yeah so we that was when we had a whole
year of releasing classes on skillshare
which made like I don't know 500k that
year probably less 400k and we released
my YouTube course which was about how to
be a part-time YouTuber uh which is not
at all what I'm known for like I should
have released a productivity course but
I was like ah people keep asking me
about this YouTube thing let me just
make a course and it was the pandemic
live cohort courses were all the rage
then with building a second brain and
right of passage and all these other
cohort-based courses so after speaking
to Thiago Forte and David Pell who ran
these courses they basically talked me
into charging loads of money for a life
cohort course and then that became like
it was meant to be a bit of a side
Hustle but it ended up being the
majority of our Revenue uh for the next
like three plus years and that is still
the cash cow that funds the entire
business basically because more than
half of our Revenue comes from this this
one course it's now Evergreen and we've
got like a service based offering on the
back of it and like a higher ticket
thing on the back of it but just
randomly this idea in a coffee shop of
like hey let me make a course about how
to do YouTube has now just like
transformed our business completely so
that was the big jump from like 100k to
130k to 1.2 million then 4 million in
2021 4.6 I think that was the last one I
saw in 2022 I think you finished a
little higher than that maybe um and
you're profiting you know the profit
margins were very good so when you made
1.2 million in Revenue your profit was
950k so like incredible profit margins I
don't know what that is roughly 80% or
something uh and then you you know
you've done two to two and a half
million of profit the last couple years
um I'm curious of two things one um why
do you think your course hit when so
many courses fail um or or fail to get
get the same type of traction is it um
what what do you what do you attribute
that to
[Music]
um why did our course hit
I think we got really lucky we got
really lucky with the timing in the
pandemic
and the thing that I would tell myself
the the thing that I would do
differently is just spend a lot of time
crafting the offer like at the time100
million offers hadn't come out I didn't
even know what an offer was I'd never
read a book about marketing I'd been on
like Russell Brunson and Neil Patel's
email list since I was like 13 but
always thought they were a bit scammy
and I was like ah what you know what
could they possibly teach me uh like you
know it's all just scammy clickfunnels
[__] um and so when we first made
the course I think we got very lucky by
just the fact that it just happened to
hit at the right time when the course
made real money was the final cohort
after I'd read $100 million offers Doom
secrets copywriting secrets and we
revamped the entire landing page the
entire off of the entire product purely
based on the advice of what Russell
Brunson and Alex hosi have written in
their books and just literally following
the step-by-step method and that was
when a single launch of the course did
like 2 million in a week isn't that
hilarious I went to the the exact exact
same thing where I'm like Russell
Brunson Neil Batel scam and then I like
start reading their stuff and I'm like
no it's not a scam at all maybe uh I I
think a lot of scammers consume that
stuff and implement it but but it's
definitely not it's really helpful stuff
yeah it's incredible stuff when I first
read.com Secrets I was like I cannot
believe I've been sitting on this for 15
years like i' I I should have been
reading all the Russell Brunson stuff
from day one essentially the the the
before and after was before when I was
selling a course I was like oh I'm
making a course and then selling the
course it's like right so like what how
can I just explain what the course is
basically it was like a very sort of
unsophisticated way of of doing things I
didn't have any formula for writing a
landing page I was just like oh I think
maybe this should go on it I was just
sort of making [__] up as I went along
and two years later when I read hundred
million offers and doom secrets and
explored this world of marketing a
little bit more that was when I realized
hang on people have been selling courses
online for like 20 years plus at this
point they've got a Playbook they've
done all the testing and one of the big
Minds shift was separating the offer
from the Fulfillment of the offer like
the thing that people are buying is the
offer and the offer needs to be a grand
slam offer to the point that people feel
like they're a dumbass for saying no to
it and then you can always worry about
the Fulfillment later and there there's
something weird about separating it into
those two of like oh okay cool so now
when when we make a course we just focus
on the offer we're like until the offer
is amazing and the landing page is
amazing we're not even going to bother
creating the course cuz like what's the
point and the creation of the course
will be sort of based on the offer is
based on like you know talking to users
and talking to people in our audience
and being like hey what do you need to
know about productivity um and then just
following a formula for like funnels in
terms of like upsells and down cells as
per the Russell Brunson method and
there's a really good book copywriting
Secrets by Jim Edwards He's like one of
Russell's like acolytes and that's
really freaking good and I was like oh
the headline is really important the
subhead is really important [__] this is
the structure of a landing page you
should talk about the users's problems
okay let's just do that and we did that
and that you know final Cod would have
course did like 2 million in a week and
I was like [__] I wish i' done this
earlier my issue with the the thing I've
read all those books too and I think
they're awesome my issue that I've
always personally challenged struggled
with is like for example in Alex Rosy's
book he was like for Jim launch or
whatever business he had he was saying
like you know we'll prove that for you
spend 40 Grand with us and then you make
$150,000 an additional Revenue like
we'll somehow prove that and if you
don't you get your money back um what so
here's like you got to make it irr IR
irresistible so of course you're going
to spend 40K you'll make 150k and I was
like yeah that's that's irresistible but
I got to figure out how to do that and
and that's actually quite challenging I
mean like it was hard just to come up I
mean I could make a landing page sound
amazing it's actually quite challenging
with the course it's a bit easier
because it's a sometimes a one-time
purchase and you just have to like be
like well here's just the information
that I've got to give them how do you
bridge that gap between fulfillment and
promise yeah this was another big um
sort of before and after moment beauty
of it you
don't that's when your team's values is
just [__] them um yeah
exactly one of the big insights from
from homo's book was this idea of like
what what's the dream outcome like what
is the actual thing that you're selling
and I didn't really I didn't really have
a have a a sense of this when we
launched the course initially and I've
been selling courses online since like I
don't know 2013 or something and I I I
just never had a sense of what is the
actual thing that we're selling what I
realized after reading the books is with
our course our YouTuber Academy the
thing we're selling is time we're saying
we will save you time and that is all
we're saying we're not saying we're
going to make you money because that's
we we cannot fulfill on that promise
because like YouTube channels like very
few succeed people have to put in the
work all that crap but we can absolutely
save you time and as soon as we changed
all of our messaging to hey we just save
you time if you value your time you
should take our course cuz we've done
all the work yeah you canol the the
internet and find all this stuff for
free if you want if you really want to
but if you value your time join our
course because we'll save you time
saving time is a very easy promise to
fulfill because obviously we're going to
fulfill it and massively overd deliver
on it and also we have a 30-day money
back guarantee if someone doesn't like
it for whatever reason we literally just
give them their money back because we
don't need the money so those two things
we save time and we give you your money
back if you don't like it that gives us
all of the conviction we need that like
actually this is a really [__] good
product because we are not promising hey
we'll make you
money do you have a so the business is
going well I think in your latest video
you're living you said you're living
nomadically now you said you're going to
do 5 point something million in Revenue
um what's do you have like a like a
Northstar where you're like I think the
business can get to hear like is there a
world are you one of these guys where
you're like I want to get to 500 billion
dollar business do you have an ambition
and what is it and what businesses are
you going to launch to get there yeah
that's a great question um I actually
don't and I'd love to get your guys take
on this um my North star
is when I'm dead and people are speaking
at my funeral I just want them to say
hey I was I was a nice dude but be that
my my my stuff helped them in some way
like helped them live a better life or
like I taught them something or
something like that like my whole North
Star is how do I continue being able to
learn synthesize and teach forever so
I'm super inspired by for example people
like Tony Robbins uh he's got his
downsides but like the cool thing is
he's been doing this stuff for 47 years
and millions of people around the world
say his stuff changed their life that's
pretty cool Tim Ferris has been doing
this stuff for like nearly 20 years and
loads of people around the world would
say he changed their life I would say
Tim F has changed my life that's pretty
cool so that's the North Star it's like
how do I just it's it's that thing of
like on once you're playing your
infinite game which is what I'm playing
right now like the only objective that
makes sense is to be able to continue
playing the game and so I don't have any
Revenue goals I don't have any profit
goals be I have a bit of a profit goal
it's like let's just make as much profit
as the year before at least please um
but beyond that I'm I'm I'm not shooting
for 10 20 50 Mill 100 million we are
building like a SAS product on the side
that I'm a sort of co-founder in you
know I I like hearing the ideas that you
guys come up with in the podcast I'm a
subscriber to Trends just to see is is
there anything interesting that I can I
can come up with here but honestly for
me the main thing is how do I just keep
on being able to make content write
books make videos do podcasts whatever
whatever formats are going to come along
in in the future to be able to teach and
so being being a good teacher is my
North Star
so please do challenge me on that
because I don't know if I'm bullshitting
myself uh well I think you're definitely
telling yourself a story but we all tell
ourselves that whatever the answer is
it's a story that one sounds like it
serves you pretty well so so keep it I
would say um you know it is probably
worth worth questioning like if I just
asked you what would be a more true
answer I think what would be more true
is I love teaching and if someone
offered me an easy way to get to 10
million I wouldn't say no to it but if
yeah so there is a number milon yeah the
funeral thing I think is uh the part
that smelled like you know where we
borrow from others versus what's
actually true in our core like what
makes us want to do something um I
personally have never been very
motivated by like my actual funeral I do
think it's a good signal it's a good
side effect of a life well-lived um but
it's not not something I would get
excited about as like I'm going to do
this because at my funeral they'll this
will be remembered you know that sort of
thing whereas it sounds like what you
really have said is you love the
learning part
you like the teaching part you may not
actually like the format you teach today
which is um like YouTube videos you kind
of admitted that you know you liked
maybe 20 of the 700 videos you enjoyed
making those but you really enjoyed the
research and the learning part that that
resonates with me I remember we did a
set of interviews in La where we tried
to book bigger name guests Mark Manson
and Brian Johnson we booked all these
guests and to do it I was like okay I'm
going to do the best job I possibly can
I'm going to research like as deep as I
can go on all these people and I I did I
went like I spent basically like two or
three full days researching each of
those people if you spend two or three
full days researching somebody you have
a PhD I have a PhD in Mark Manson like I
I have fully researched him like I I
went and found he was like had this
pickup artist alra ego back in the day
and I went and read all his stuff and
then I read his first book that nobody
even talks about models rather than the
subtle art great book read all of it
right and
so then and I had so much fun doing it I
didn't do three days because it needed
three days probably needed three hours
but I got into it and I could justify it
because I had this big interview booked
and we booked the studio so I could
justify doing whatever the hell I want
and so I indulged myself and just went
further because I was enjoying it then
came the actual interview and he's a
great guy interview turned out fine but
it was like a seven or eight compared to
the fun I had in actually like going
down the rabbit hole myself and actually
trying to learn things uh it sounds like
that might be true for you too where you
the 10 out of 10 is the learning and the
seven out of 10 is recording the content
for for YouTube yeah I think for me me
the the the learning is 10 out of 10 I I
think teaching in real life is also a 10
out of 10 like when I go back through my
life and think of the most meaningful
moments like I quite enjoyed being a
doctor but I enjoyed it way more when I
had a medical student attached to me who
I could teach along the way and you know
on days where I didn't have someone I
was teaching I would kind of be looking
forward to going home so I could make
YouTube videos but on days where I did
have someone I was teaching alongside i'
the time would just fly I wouldn't be
thinking oh you know when's the day
going to end I'd be thinking [__] love
this this is so fun um so I want to do
more like live seminar live teaching e
type things next year that's something
we've got in the pipeline my my therapy
my end of my therapy session for you is
I think the actual North Star should be
if your learning is a 10 out of 10 today
find a way to turn the teaching into a
10 out of 10 and then you've won right
because then you're literally just doing
the [__] you you you truly
enjoy in the infinite game you can do
that forever I also think Ali that like
so my [__] detector was going off
when you were telling me what your goals
are are because I think that you can
have multiple goals so I think that I
think that I believe what you're saying
about how you how you want to be
remembered and all that but I think that
it doesn't sound I think it sounds like
crude to say like well I would like to
hit 10 million in Revenue Maybe by year
eight or whatever and I I and I think
that maybe you didn't say that because
it sounds crude but I think that that's
perfectly that's a wonderful goal I I
think that like with me personally I
think of this business thing you're past
the point where it you you have security
I think that it's the same way that when
you're exercising you know you're like I
want to run a 5k at this time um I'm not
going to be devastated if I don't do it
but it's just a really fun goal to chase
after and I think that's the same with a
lot of business stuff which is you want
to net worth by this age or you want
your business to hit this much in
revenue or profit or users and I don't
think that you need to stake your
personal or your self-esteem or your
personal self-worth on it but I still
think it's exciting like when it's like
man this new SAS thing I'm working on
maybe one day this could make this much
in revenue and if it doesn't it could
still be awesome so long as I enjoyed it
but that's just exciting you know like
it's an exciting thing to shoot for or
uh and I think that's okay to admit that
but for some reason it seems like you
didn't want to yeah I don't know
I'm the thing that excites me is is and
again I this could just be a story story
but it honestly is that thing of I just
want to learn and share cool stuff and
that focus on the process focus on the
things that are in my control has led to
like the the score takes care of itself
when you focus on the things that are on
that that are in your control let me ask
you a question you had this story about
your the first business you ever
launched and you were 18 years old and
it didn't go well tell the story of this
thousand business that you had when you
were 18 years old what happened uh yeah
so uh This was
um from from like Agee 16 to 18 I was
doing some like private tutoring I was
teaching people how to do well in maths
and science exams and [__] and I saved
up about $1,000 and then I was like okay
I'm I'm rich now I can buy my first
Apple product I was like yeah I can
finally finally afford an Apple product
and so I went out to try and find a
MacBook Air and I bought one of some
dude on Craigslist uh but it turned out
after it transpired that he sold me a
model that didn't work and it was really
old and I was a dumbass so I didn't
realize that he was selling me a kind of
a dead a dead MacBook and so this $
th000 that I'd spent like years of my
life working every week like hours of
private tutoring like $10 an hour to get
to this thousand suddenly all that
disappeared and I was like cool I need
to find a way to recoup these losses I
need to find a way to build a business
that allows me to make this money back
and so I still have the Evernote file
from 2012 when when I was 18 where that
happened where I was like okay what am I
good at I'm good at teaching I'm good at
med school entrance exams I know how to
make websites so let me build a business
that combines all those things and that
was my first business like I've been
trying to make money on the internet
since age 13 hence why I was on Russell
Brunson and Neil Patel's email list
since then but that was the first
business I made that actually succeeded
where I had this strong desire to do it
and found this combination of things
that I was already good at and then that
business did like 10K E1 100K E2 150k E3
and actually sold that business a few
years ago to go full-time on the YouTube
channel um but because my YouTube
channel originally started off as
content marketing for that original
business which was teaching courses of
how to get into med school I've probably
I don't know in total yoube Channel and
all the stuff around it's probably done
over 10 million Revenue so my $1
thousand loss which was like felt
lifechanging at the time has now
transformed into like a 10 million kind
of upside um and I feel kind of like
that's kind of cool like at the time I
thought to myself I'm going to find a
way to turn this thousand loss into a
really good opportunity and that was
when that first business really really
started and and took
off Sam have you ever had that have you
ever had like a big L that turned that
what felt like like a big L in the
moment that turned into a w my whole
thing was uh like just growing up where
like my parents controlled money and
where it was like you you're not allowed
to do this or you know like when your
parents say like well if you're living
under my roof you're G to do this and I
there's been many times where I was like
at a very young age I was like all right
fine money equals power then and then
basically everything that I've done
since then has been because my parents
probably because they said to me a
handful of times and I said all right
then I'm going to be completely free and
money is one way to achieve that freedom
um yeah yeah I mean it all stems
basically every great business person I
think probably stems from some type of
childhood trauma whether it's your
parents telling you no or you see your
mother uh be poor or you get scammed out
of a
Macbook when we sold the milk Road I
asked the guys I was like man you guys
have been they've just been doing
different businesses for so so long and
they had a pretty interesting track
record like small wins big wins [__]
like that and um I was like what's the
driver because like you know once you if
you Bank a100 million and you're still
taking risk in starting businesses like
you're not doing it for the money I
don't believe and uh I was like what's
the driver or what's and he's like I
don't know what it is now he's like but
for a long time he's like both of them
had the same story and it wasn't like
this wasn't on the podcast this wasn't
to look cool this was like us hanging
out and he said it matter of factly he's
like yeah this girl reject to me when I
was like 14 years old and he's like I
like I literally felt like [__] and I
was like okay like I don't want to be
rejected again how do I make myself
awesome and he's like I didn't know what
the answer was but I immediately started
to be like Oh I'm if I'm if I'm okay at
this I'm good at this I'm gonna become
awesome at this instead and so he's like
I was good at like the internet making
websites stuff like that and I just like
went into overdrive and he's like the
other guy had the same story he's like
yeah I lived in this he's like I had six
friends and in college and they had H we
wanted to live off campus together and
they got a house that only had five
rooms and I was the odd man out and I
was just like [__] these guys I'm gonna
okay I'm gonna go live in my by myself
but I'm gonna like I'm gonna go into the
hole and I'm gonna come out a different
guy Sean because you seem like you've
had your act together I mean you've seen
emotionally
stable yeah I've had a few things like
this probably not like not like some
huge disrespect or nothing I was that
aware of but I do remember
like I remember hearing this story so I
went to this I got into this random
accelerator that I don't even know if it
exists anymore it's called the mass
Challenge and they used to invite these
speakers in was in Massachusetts and uh
one time was at this this event they had
in uh Ben from Ben and Jerry's was there
and he told this story about Ben and
about the starting story of Ben and
Jerry's there's all these like
interesting funny things like he starts
it off being like yeah I met Jerry cuz
we were both like in PE class and and uh
I was like you know there people like
did you guys get along right away he's
like no but we were both the fat kids so
like we would have to run the mile every
day and um we were just walking at the
back and like first we didn't talk for
the first two weeks and finally it's
like all right what up man like you know
it's you again and so they became
friends that way and he talks about like
you know they start this they take this
five he uh one of them was trying to get
into med school and he failed the
entrance exam five or six times in a row
um so like you know he basically for
several years couldn't get into bed
school and so they instead took a $5 ice
cream making course together and uh
that's like you know part of how they
learned how to make ice cream for Ben
and Jerry's so they open up this shop
and uh it wasn't like pints like you see
today it was a shop but it was in
Vermont in the freezing cold winter and
uh so they're about to go out of
business like in month three because
nobody wants ice cream when it's already
they snowing outside it's like a
blizzard outside and so they uh you know
they they're all right what do we do
we're screwed so what do we do and they
had this uh that came up with this
promotion it's like this long acronym
like nine letters long and it stood for
one cent off per degree celsius under
you know freezing or whatever and so you
got like 12 cents off if it was 12 below
freezing and so they uh and that like
that promotion was funny people liked it
so they like came and like pied them and
basically B bought a little ice cream
took them through the winter so then
they were like still struggling and they
started the strategy of like making
pints they're like oh let's go to
restaurants and give them the pints
because otherwise it's just going to
melt here nobody's coming to our shop
and eventually they get into corner
stores and they start selling and
finally the business is working and
they're like oh my God this is great we
sell we sell pints to these corner
stores and they sell our product for us
this is a good business and then one day
um like they stopped getting orders from
like a whole area in uh where they lived
and they were like what the hell
happened they go and they talk to the
store owner he's like oh guys I didn't
want to tell you this but you know I got
word from from big ice cream he's like
what he's like yeah hog and came to us
and uh hogendas which is owned by
Pillsbury Pillsbury sent us this letter
said I don't know who this Ben and Jerry
is but like you need to stop selling
their stuff only sell hogendas uh or
we're pulling all Pillsbury products
from your shelves he's like dude he's
like I need my crescent rolls I can't do
I can't do this guys I'm so sorry and so
the guys are like [__] we're screwed but
they had this value which was like turn
the disadvantage into an advantage and
so they were like all right how can we
use this and so they created this
um whole campaign called what's the
Doughboy afraid of and they would put a
they would print these like posters that
were like the pint of Ben and& Jerry's
with the giant like do Pillsbury
Doughboy hands about to strangle it and
they would just say what's a doughboy
afraid of and then on every pint of ice
cream they sold they said we're under
attack call this number to hear the
story about what's going on why
Pillsbury is trying to put out your
favorite uh ice cream brand and then
they recorded like an answering machine
that would just tell the three-minute
story and say like if you think this is
screwed up buy these stickers and buy
pint of ice cream just to you know show
Pillsbury you won't you won't be bullied
and eventually the New Yorker takes the
story and you know Jerry standing
outside of pillsbury's headquarters by
himself picketing as if he's a protester
and they take this picture they' run
this in the New Yorker and Pillsbury has
to like completely back off because it
looks terrible for them as a you know as
a brand to be doing this and secondly a
whole bunch of people found out about
Ben and Jerry that didn't know about it
before because this story was a lot more
interesting than just here's a cool ice
cream brand started with these hippies
and Vermont and so then they exploded in
sales and that they became successful
and I remember hearing that and so
everything that would happen in our
first business like we were you know 20
years old basically trying to start the
sushi chain everything that would happen
we'd get rejected or we' get a cease and
assist letter or whatever it was we were
like this is our pillsberry moment all
right what's the dough boy afraid of how
do we flip this and so very quickly it
went from like anything that was bad we
got hyped because it was like this could
be our story that we're telling someday
and that just became like
embedded in my mind and so I almost
don't even remember the individual like
kind of like rejection moments because
it was all like all right how are we
going to use this to go viral how are we
going to use this to uh to our advantage
and that's just like I don't know what
I've been doing for like 15 years since
by the way olly welcome to my life so I
asked Sean a question he tells me this
amazing story where I'm totally
enthralled I was into it he does such a
good job of telling the story and I'm
like I don't even know what to say I'm
interested wor yeah like fall down this
slope but I'm like I don't remember what
I asked but like what else you got keep
keep tell me tell me another tell me
learn from you ollie I want to learn uh
about titles so I think that one of the
reason your course does so well is that
it's not called you know how to be how
to you know be famous on YouTube It's
called The part-time YouTuber Academy
and part-time I think just appeals to a
whole different segment of people and I
always think about these choices because
when you see the title what you don't
see is the 50 other options that were
considered and I think about this with
like your entire Channel like if I go to
your YouTube channel right now and I by
U let's say popular right um you know
some of your titles are just really good
you know how I type really fast all caps
and then 156 words per minute or um how
I ranked first at Cambridge University
the essay and you're the thumbnails
you're holding up like this notebook
that looks like it's got you know the
secret instructions inside or my
evidence-based skincare routine so even
though I said you weren't the most
beautiful guy you got good skin and you
but saying my evidence-based skare
routine is so different than just saying
my skincare routine um I'm curious
what's your method to Madness on getting
good at titles or how you come up with
the stuff yeah nice um we think a lot
about titles what we found basically is
that the only thing that allows us to
predict the performance of a video is
just the title it's not even the
thumbnail some people like thumbnail but
like in in an educational Channel my
thumbnails look broadly similar it's
it's very rarely the thumbnail it just
tends to be the title if we know that if
the title is good then by default the
content is going to be at least
reasonable and useful that's our main
thing is like is this useful and so the
video is going to fly or Flop based on
the performance of the title how do you
know the title will be good though by
the way that's the same offer separating
the offer from the delivery of the of
the offer is the same principle right
exactly it was the same thing for the
book you know we it took like about a
100 iterations to land on Feelgood
productivity as like the thing we had I
have still got my Apple notes follow
with like hundreds of title options
trying to get at this idea of like being
productive in a nice fun joyful sort of
way and the title actually came to me in
the shower like two years into the
Journey of writing the book on just on
that note one thing I would do
differently next time is any feature
book that I write I would make sure I've
got the title nailed before trying to
write the book because the title informs
the concept and the hook which informs
everything else and there was so much
like surgery we had to do on the book
once we came up with that title to be
like ah okay that's the title so now
let's rejig everything in the book to
make sure it like matches the promise
you know the the offer the title in the
thumbnail of of the book um but when it
comes to YouTube videos we just do a lot
of iteration he's like how do you know a
good title from a bad like when you're
when you're trying to decide what what
are your obviously it's just a judgment
call over time you get a bunch of
intuition but is there anything you do
or anything that led you to be better at
titles yeah we do a lot um we we have
the strategy that we cutely called viral
replication which is that by the the way
you grow a YouTube channel is by getting
a viral video and the easiest way to get
a viral video is to just copy the title
of another video that's already gone
viral so a lot of our best titles have
been just looking around on YouTube
sometimes within an nich sometimes
outside of an nich and looking at the
view to subscriber ratio of that
particular video so like back in the day
I saw some guy May made a video like how
I use my iPad as an engineering student
I was like okay interesting but that
video had like 2 million views and the
dude had like 20,000 subscribers I was
like huh that's that's interesting
there's something about that title
that's really popped so I thought how I
use my iPad as a medical student sounds
cool so I made that video and that was
the first video on the channel that went
viral that got over a million views I
was like huh six million views and it's
how I take notes on my iPad Pro in
medical school is that the one yeah
that's the one um and that was the that
was about a year into my channel yeah
are you using software to help you do
this or you just browsing uh we're
browsing we're using vid IQ the Chrome
extension which shows us the sub
subscribe account of the channel just
next to their name because otherwise you
have to click on it and see what the
Subscribe account is um we've also now
started becoming more sophisticated with
AB testing titles and thumbnails so we
use thumbnail test.com uh which is made
by one of our Twitter friends to just
test the [__] out of the back catalog um
and that generates a bunch of free views
basically every day because we can
refresh an old video that's like three
years old by just giving it a new title
or a new thumbnail it's a lot of like
repeating that process over and over
again before landing on a title we often
have like 20 titles to choose from and
sometimes if we're really not sure we'll
like test it on Twitter and on Instagram
and on YouTube Community post we'll say
hey which of these four titles would you
be more likely to click on and often
there's like a clear winner and we're
okay cool let's just do that and we make
sure we don't even think about writing
the video until we have nailed a title
because obviously like the the framing
of the title and thumbnail radically
informs the way you can do the
video our producer by the way I just saw
her look down she's like taking notes on
how we can improve our Channel what's
the um what's the
software bit you're fooling around with
because I bet you've seen a lot of
interesting creators launch cool
businesses I bet you've had a lot of
opportunities run by you why did you
sell this one and what is it yeah so
this is uh we're actually launching like
this week uh it's called voice pel and
it's like a a voice notes meets AI
transcription meets converting your
voice note into like a summary which you
can then turn into a tweet thread or a
LinkedIn post or a journal entry or
whatever you want uh it's not launched
yet voice. me for whenever people are
listening to this it will have been
launched by then uh this is an idea I've
I've kind of had floating in the back of
my mind partly thanks to listening to
your guys' pod for a few years which is
that creators have a massive
distribution Advantage but do not know
how to make products uh product people
know how to make products but really
struggle with distribution So in theory
if you can combine those two things if
you can pair a creator with a product
that fits Their audience nicely now
you're winning because the product guy
makes a product and the Creator has the
distribution and so I partnered up with
a friend of mine who's a second time
founder he's exited like two well third
time founder he's exited two companies
um and he was like hey we should totally
build some cool productivity software
together and I was like yes we
absolutely should and so the first idea
that we're launching is this thing
called voice pal which is like yeah you
record a voice note and it transcribes
it and it can turn it into whatever
whatever you want and we're trying to
figure out like the messaging around
this like double your productivity using
your voice something to that something
to that effect and we're going to be
launching this week for our thousand
beta testers and I'll post it on Twitter
and Linkedin and the newsletter and
hopefully we'll just get those thousand
people very quickly how much you going
to charge yeah we're thinking like $10 a
month initially um we've already got
like 20 paying users uh from the alpha
friends and family test that we did
where we s of found 30 people like 20 of
them were like super super power users
and almost all of them converted to paid
when Pablo the co-founder reached out to
them to be like hey would you like to
buy Early Access to this and a lot of
people are using it already for like
journalists and like lawyer and stuff
for like recording depositions and and
things like that a bunch of people are
using it for journaling as well so one
thing that I'm really bullish on is like
you know to to your point about wouldn't
it be cool to get to 10 million Revenue
I think the way we get there is I don't
try and get there through content but we
try and get there through building cool
software products on the side that I
that I use personally that I would like
oh I would [__] love a journaling app
that does this I'd love a to-do list app
that's different to things and to do is
by doing this I think that's so smart
and then we plug it to our audience I
think that's I think I I I think I would
agree with that that theory of you're
not going to get to where you want to go
by doing the content Revenue itself have
you guys seen the app opal so it's opal.
so it's like um no man you guys got to
check this out so opal. Soo so it says
find your focus make the most of every
day with the world's greatest screen
time software so the problem with iPhone
software is that you know like the
screen time thing you can just click
like Bypass or whatever so somehow these
guys made it to where I can't bypass so
between eight or nine and 6 p.m. I
cannot go on social media on my phone
and they've done it in such a way that
like I I literally can't bypass it and
it's like
$120 they've got a crazy amount of
reviews and I think that what I think is
going to happen is I think I I think
there's already a lot of these but these
like screen time Focus session app apps
I think historically have done pretty
good so they're there's a few ones for
the past couple years um there's Chrome
plugins for this but this one in
particular is the only one that's stuck
with me um I don't I have no idea who
these guys are this isn't like a
promotion I just I just thought it was
cool I could see you launching something
like this I think they charge $200 $300
for a lifetime license and then $100 a
year um but I really like like if I'm
you I would just look at what are the
most what are the best uh apps out there
for productivity who's spending the most
on advertising and how do I acquire a
small part of their company or something
similar because I don't have to my
margin will be their advertising
budget yeah that is like exactly the way
we're thinking we're sort of thinking of
it as a sort of barbell strategy where
there there's a couple of companies that
I've invested in to get like a small
Equity stake in in the company rise is
one of them r i z uh they're like
another focused time tracking e type
thing that I've been using for like two
years and so we we invested in them but
we invested sponsorship dollars so like
however much it was like four
sponsorships worth of investment into
the company and it's great because I use
it every day I love it it's easy to
recommend and when I say I've invested
in a thing it's like people like oh he
like he liked it so much he actually
invested in it so that's for a small
Equity stake and then on the other side
we're trying to do the sort of
co-founding uh software product for like
a 20 or 30% Equity stake so I'm trying
to try and experiment with both but I'm
particularly bullish on like building
our own [__] because I think that's
where I get to mold the direction of the
product in a way that personally suits
me and one of the cool things about that
is like what I love trying to find is
apps
where but apps where I can share a
screenshot of the thing which promotes
the app without it looking like a
promotion so for example whenever I do a
workout I use the app strong and I just
screenshot it and post it on my
Instagram story and I will always get
like dozens of comments being like what
app is that right annoys me because I'm
like this is an app I don't own and it's
just really good but if I did own the
app strong or a workout tracker and I
was just posting screenshots of my
workouts no one would think I'm plugging
a product they would think oh he's
sharing screenshots of his product right
so I'm I'm always looking for for these
organic promotion opportunities that
don't look like they're that they don't
look like they're or like another one is
SC scrier is that what it's called I
know you love that app that writing app
which I think it's just like a guy in
like Montana or something like you know
a little bit random like that who owns
that writing tool um but you should
acquire stakes in these businesses or
launch some of their own and I think
you'd be very successful at that yeah
yeah one thing I've been thinking a lot
is that with a lot of these productivity
apps they tend they tend not to be
differentiated on the product itself
like fundamentally all to-do list apps
do the same thing and when you watch
reviews of them it's like oh well things
three has slightly nicer animations and
todoist has like teams and this one is
available on iPad so you should get that
it's like the the the product features
that that differentiate these are so
small so if we could in theory just
clone one of these with in our own way
in our own design language whatever and
we've got feature parity on the product
side we would have a distribution
advantage and the market for these
productivity apps is so huge that like
you know a few users would be would be
pretty good how many users to let's say
if you owned scrier or opal how many
users could a handful of your videos
Drive do you think um probably thousands
to tens of thousands based on what the
uses are that we drive to like
skillshare and Brilliant and these other
like sponsor type things if there's a
good fit with the audience then yeah
there was a time where Sean brought up
some company that does accounting or his
taxes on the Pod um and then afterwards
he asked he I don't think Sean you
didn't have any he didn't he had no
stake he was just like I just met this
guy and it was cool and I ended up using
their product and it was interesting
here's what it was and then he like
hollered at them two weeks later and was
like did you see a bump and the guy was
like raving you know I don't know what
numbers I'm allowed to say or not but
Sean you could decide if you want to say
it or not but it was like a substantial
sum and your cend Le was booked out like
four months or something like that I
don't know if they didn't have a lot of
slots or what happened but like that was
uh that was great for them um when when
that happened yeah but then we both had
a light bulb moment and we're like yeah
oh there's something there you know what
I mean um now of course you have to pick
and choose which ones you do and you
can't do too many at one time you
probably should only do one at a time
for a certain amount of time but yeah
like we had that same moment as well um
so one thing that we did we so we
recently launched well recently a a few
months ago um a studio called Hey
friends which is like a done hun and sah
yeah with Hunter and sahill oh yeah
because like you you guys are working
with them as well um and one tweet from
me and yeah just like one tweet drove
two million mrr worth of leads that
they're still like going through the
sales calls and like trying to shore up
capacity because there's so many people
this 14,000 uh Mr
worth wow okay that's a [__] yeah there
were like literally hundred hundreds of
people that signed up for a 14,000 a
month sales call and they were like [__]
like we can only onboard like one or two
people a month cuz we need to hire
editors and script writers and all this
kind of stuff and it was just like one
tweet and Twitter is isn't even my main
platform but I guess it's where people
with people people like you guys are
more likely to read a tweet of mine than
watch a video so if I'm like hey I've
got this 15K a month YouTube as a
service thing it's like that drove so
many leads and we're like H that's
interesting capacity now we did this
thing I think two years ago Sean or
maybe no maybe a year ago we we were
like okay so we understand how there's
these billion dooll businesses built on
Instagram that that's been done uh maybe
a couple times uh with the Kardashians
and a handful of other people it's very
plausible that it's happening or has
already happened with YouTube Mr Beast
and there's whoever you know there's
many more that have built businesses
that are worth hundreds of millions of
dollars maybe even more on YouTube it
hasn't happened yet with Twitter and our
prediction was like this is going to
happen more and the reason it's going to
happen more is because a there's a
business audience on Twitter a bit more
than those other platforms so you can
sell higher pric things and B the
conversions quite high so like I don't
know what the click theough rate on your
video so how many people click a link to
to your products it probably is less
than 1% on Twitter it's not crazy that
to be 5% at times we post a link and 5%
of people click it and we're like wow we
could just drive way more traffic to a
website it hasn't happened yet I think
it's in the process of happening
hopefully Sean and I and a couple of our
friends are are in route to doing that
but I think it's gonna happen in the
next five issu who's even Twitter famous
right like I can I can go on YouTube and
Instagram and I know like oh I don't
know who Charlie demilio is but I know
that that's a person that's Tik Tok
famous like started on that platform got
huge on that platform has a huge fan
base on that platform you could say Dan
Bilzerian and others were doing that on
Instagram when Instagram first came out
and on YouTube you had you know whoever
tons tons of people Mr Beast and others
I don't even know who that would be on
Twitter like who the hell is Twitter
famous like sahill maybe sah is our
friend sahill the most Twitter famous
guy out that that's the biggest like no
F to sill sahill is great but like
shouldn't it be a famous person like
shouldn't there be like the whoever you
know like like Mr Beast is like massive
PewDiePie was massive these were like
massive massive creators who is that on
Twitter I don't even know like is there
and I'm on Twitter all the I guess you
or our friends I don't I don't know it
can't
be think why does it not have that
that's insane I think it also really
depends on what audience you're going up
like normal people have never heard of
SEL Bloom the only people who have are
the people who are in our sort of like
business yeah that's what I'm saying so
who's Mass market like you know on
Instagram it was like beautiful people
went they were the mass Market famous
people right and then on YouTube it's
like the funny vlogger Types on Twitch
it was like best fortnite player in the
world all right fortnite's super popular
makes sense that Ninja's super popular
and Dr disrespecting these guys shroud
whoever I don't even know who those
people are on Twitter who is like like
is it Elon is he the only guy who is
like or famous on Twitter oh yeah Trump
like they're famous they were famous off
Twitter which is why they're big on
Twitter like is there anybody who's just
natively so good at tweeting that they
just got huge because if not something
is broken about this platform it's not
broken my point is it's small it's small
so how many how many users does Twitter
have I don't know three or 400 million
million yeah yeah a fraction compared to
what the other platforms have so it's
just small um and also it's text based
so it's a little bit less EX so like uh
and you don't exactly see like the view
count like you do on YouTube so I see
Ali's video that has 6 million views and
I'm like oh many other people know this
person I'll see a tweet just randomly
through my my feed and I don't NE it's
more one to one versus one to many so I
don't know that other people's are
people are consuming it but that's okay
it's no it's there is no famous people
but that's okay you I think you could
still build a big business because
there's people like Ali or you or I on
there who will SP money years Twitter's
like 20 years old it's if it's not big
now it's never getting big like it's a
20-y old product there's 300 million
people what like who's more than 10
million followers is there like who who
is not already famous like Trump and
Elon take them out that has more than 10
million followers organic I don't know
like I know that got popular right like
you that's insane to Me Maybe it's like
a couple yeah there's maybe some of
these like crazy you know like fjerry
like is there even like an fjerry type
of account on
Twitter I don't know I don't think so is
somebody who knows is just yelling at
their podcast player right now like why
aren't they saying blah blah blah
obvious so we're all friends with the
most famous guy on Twitter s Bloom yeah
congrats and what is it that you say a
dwarf amongst midgets yeah that's
basically what's going on here like uh
well the only reason he's famous is
because he's Indian so he has a billion
potential fans and he's ripped so he's
already's G to track all the dudes by
the way it's never women that are
attracted to the rip dudes it's always
other men like me who see a RI guy uh
and he like talk talks about
productivity so he's got this whole
other angle so he's like this he's a
he's a triple
[Laughter]
assassin he gets Indian followers he's
not Indian he's also half Indian so he's
super hot also right like amazing
combination of dude if he had Alli
accent it'd be over yeah if he had a
British or a London accent and was sound
it all proper he he's got it all he's uh
he'd be he he'd had everything um Ali
thanks for doing this man the name of
the book what is it Feelgood
productivity it's coming out in January
or December 26 right yeah December 26th
feel good productivity it's about how to
do more of a to you in a way that's
right enjoyable meaningful sustainable
yeah yeah did you not know that most
gifts are bought literally three days
before that exactly [__] good point
procrastination date for the prot there
there was this whole like astrology that
the Publishers did where they were like
well if we go before Christmas we're
competing with cookbooks and like
celebrity Memoirs and those are often
gifted over Christmas rather than like
self-help books but if we go just after
Christmas people are on a new year new
me kind of thing so maybe that's when
it'll hit I'm not sure how much of this
was astrology versus like actual data
but I mean they seem pretty switched on
so so maybe there was some data behind
it as well and your cover looks like an
air table spread sheet the cover we okay
here here's the thing with with these
sort of books the the reason Atomic
habits was so successful is because it
was picked up by the demographic of uh
women in their 30s in the midwest
apparently
which is like by far the biggest
demographic of people who buy books and
especially people who buy self-help
books and it really hit that crowd like
sometime in the pandemic K of the world
a bunch of a bunch of ladies named
kiny yeah that kind of thing you know
they got two kids that kind stuff and so
the publisher was like look productivity
is too broy we we need to have a cover
that will be a bit more gender neutral
feel a bit more like kind of fresh and
inviting and yeah productivity is likeon
D yeah good point yeah sounds about
right um but that's why the cover is all
like bright and colorful and St it's
also my vibe I like bright and colorful
well the landing page is beautiful it
looks good man you're going to kill it
congratulations on all this um thanks
man than thanks for uh giving us shout
outs and and we'll uh we'll have to
repay you in some way when your book
comes out and and we'll share it but we
appreciate you coming on and uh we'll
wrap up here that's the
[Music]
pod